in person just down the road from the
lakers front offices here in el segundo
california the controlling owner and CEO
of the los angeles lakers Jeanie buss
good to see you Jeannie
good morning anything going on with you
lately well tonight is Laker night at
Dodger Stadium okay I'm gonna be at
Dodger Stadium okay yeah so magic has
some good contacts Laker night at Dodger
Stadium it's actually we're gonna you
know present some jerseys to some of the
Dodger players that might have the
number 23 on them may or may not right
okay so you know it just it's if we've
we find that our fan base is really
crossover that we're very we have you
know people who love the Dodgers usually
our Laker fans - yeah vice versa right
Louis Lakers lost doors here in Los
Angeles short so let's start I guess
with obviously LeBron I mean it's a huge
free agent signing to say the least
what would your dad think of this right
now Jeannie you know I it felt you know
very like a familiar feeling that when
we got Shaquille O'Neal as a free agent
in 1996 it kind of felt the same way
which that is the formula kind of the
the way dr. bust like to do things is to
go after the best and you know put
together the best team he can to play
and represent the Lakers right and so it
feels shades of 96 right now yeah I mean
it it you know the idea that you know
LeBron chose to come to the Lakers that
he he knows what we're building he knows
the the roster that we have he knows we
have a lot of young players you know
that he wanted to be a part of what
we're doing shows you know it validates
the work that Magic Johnson and Rob
polenka have done to kind of you know
turn the tide for the team because we
hadn't made the playoffs
in five years and we're hoping that that
adding you know a player like LeBron and
and and the veterans that we've added
like Lance Stephenson and Rajon Rondo
and JaVale McGee and Michael Beasley
that you know will have the the nice
combination that we will get the Lakers
back into contention so well let's let's
talk about the LeBron nuts-and-bolts of
the acquisition here Jeanne bus here on
the Rich Eisen show so as the word as
has been mentioned magic rings the
doorbell one LeBron James here on the
west side of Los Angeles right at 9:00
Pacific
midnight Eastern when it was first
allowed for him to ring the doorbell
question where were you at that moment I
was at home kind of watching things you
know unfold with you know some of the
other free agent signings that word were
taking place that night and certainly I
was anxious to see how things went with
magic but I know he was going over to
his house yes I did know he was going
over there III knew they were meeting I
actually didn't know where it was going
to be interesting and so you know I
would expect you know some kind of
feedback and we really didn't know you
know they had a good meeting a
productive meeting I think when you have
two players that have so much in common
in terms of their you know they played
in the Midwest that they you know both
have won championships and they're both
about making their teams better that
they had a lot in common and they they
had a good conversation but really you
know no decision was made at that time
and I was just hoping that things would
go our way but there was really no
deadline as to when he would decide are
you texting magic during this how's it
going or are you just sitting back and I
know I know you you you can't have a
better emissary right and you are
delegating
your role as controlling owner but I
mean are you well I mean I wasn't
delegate I was empowering like I have
complete faith in Magic Johnson in terms
of his ability to be a leader to know
how to put together our winner and you
know I have patience and and I think
what he's done has exceeded my
expectations how quickly they've kind of
turned around the roster I think Rob
polenka has done a great job you know
handling the you know the salary cap is
is really important I hate talking about
things
it sounds so you know just about the the
slotting and in the cap space and all
that it just sounds so impersonal but
Rob blinka has a great grasp on that and
together they knew what they wanted and
certainly LeBron is a person who has
earned his free agency he's been a free
agent
a couple times in his career and you
know he was going to make a decision
that was going to be best for him
whatever that criteria was for him and
I'm just glad that everything worked out
so that he chose our team to shorten
Jeanie buss here in the Rich Eisen show
so when did you insert yourself into the
process you know I you know I didn't
have to I didn't sound like an
assortment over to his house and note
from that to hand him from I think what
what I think what people have to see is
what you know since I made the decision
to change the the front office of our
basketball operations 18 months ago or
not even 18 months ago that every
decision that was made bringing in
magic-magic hiring Rob pálinka you know
the the players that they've drafted the
the way they developed players in our
with our G league team every decision
that they made shows a path to where
they're going for a while it was
difficult for me to see what Laker
basketball was because we
were changing coaches every eighteen
months and you can't create an identity
there there seem to be a lack of
stability in terms of you know where our
vent Allah would be and and when magic
came in that kind of settled down and
and you could begin to see what kind of
personality the Laker team was going to
have what Laker basketball stands for
and so you know drafting players like
Kyle Kuzma and Josh Hart and Lanza ball
and the the continued development of
Brandon Ingram you can see what Laker
basketball stands for coach Luke Walton
has done a great job getting everybody
to buy into what his vision is and so
now we have an identity and I think when
you're a free agent because it's very
difficult for a player to get to that
point in their career where they have
the opportunity to choose where they
want to go and you know so for free
agents to see that we you know that we
are cohesive that were that we're
building something so that when they
entrust their choice their career to us
that they know they're not going to be
shortchanged so the night that magic
talked to LeBron mm-hmm you didn't know
where the meeting was taking place you
got a lot of text when he left saying I
think we're looking good I mean
basically had a great conversation and
you know we'll see what happens and then
were you surprised that the jury came
back so quickly I was I was relieved
that it came back so quickly and you
know I found out pretty much like how
everybody else did by a text on my phone
from rich Paul LeBron's agent just
saying congratulations and you know I
get chills I think about it now I
actually you know and and what that
means and and I got choked up I thought
about what that would have meant to dr.
boss and you know just and and also to
the fans who've been so patient with us
because
we hadn't delivered a product you know
that was you know consistent with the
product that we'd been delivering for 30
years over 30 years so you know I just I
felt honored and validated for all the
the changes that we made in the
direction that we're taking the team so
when was the first time you conversed
with LeBron on this subject bus you know
I really haven't I've only had one
conversation with them and it was brief
because he was at our facility working
out and he didn't have a shirt on
standing there talking to somebody
sweating and you know it kind of in the
middle of his workout but I just wanted
to him to know how much I appreciated
that he made the decision to join us
well I also noticed that you were one of
the many that was tweeting or responding
about his school and some of the
comments that were made from Washington
DC on that subject I mean is that
something that you know wondering where
obviously you you now have a
relationship with LeBron in this regard
why did you do that yeah I mean I you
know just because I haven't had a chance
to talk to him one-on-one doesn't mean
that I haven't watched and appreciated
that the choices that he's made what
he's decided to stand up for what he's
decided to invest in
I think he's he is proven to be a leader
amongst his peers he is you know making
a decision to to change lives
and to invest in the young people in his
community where he grew up where he
knows he could make a change and he
knows that you know by investing dollars
in and showing that leadership that it
will encourage others his peers to do
likewise so so much conversation has
been made since this signing as to what
would be the measuring stick for LeBron
James's success here in
Los Angeles for this franchise that
folks just just the photograph that we
posted a view on our Twitter account
promoting that you were here I lost
track of the number of Larry O'Brien
championship trophies that are behind
you in this photograph
what is your from the top of the
flowchart management measuring stick of
what success would look like for LeBron
James here in Los Angeles
well I think for an organization for the
Laker organization we are are not going
to rest until we're proud and you know
there has been so much you know Magic
has brought championships and and pride
to the team as a player and I expect the
same from him as you know the face of
our franchise so when does a trophy need
to be added to you behind that
photograph there used to be a measuring
stick for success it's so difficult to
win a championship I mean everything has
to align the right way you have to to
you know avoid injuries everything has
to just come together and it's so rare
it's like lightning striking but but
what in my position as the the owner as
the controlling owner is to make sure
that we have all the pieces in place so
that we can be contenders that we can be
part of the conversation and that's what
we've missed the last five years is that
you can't you you can't have a chance a
path a journey to a championship if
you're not even in the playoffs I want
to take a break
Jeannie bus with you when we come back I
do want to hit on something that I'm
scratching my head over is that the
die-hard Kobe fans in this town
appear to have an issue a little bit
with LeBron coming to this team and I do
want to hit on that subject in a little
bit more with you here on the show okay
Jeannie bus is here on the Rich Eisen
show we are back with the controlling
owner and CEO of the Los Angeles Lakers
all right while the radiance is away
Jeanie buss we noticed a couple of
photographs on your social media
platforms we wanted to get a little bit
of a backstory Jeanie buss on Twitter
and also Instagram yes okay okay let's
check this one out first we noticed this
flashback Friday
yeah do you have a speaking role in this
no I did and I was just an extra but you
know Tobey Maguire is a big Lakers fan
and so he invited me to be you know just
an extra but I
I love horse racing San Anita
it's a beautiful track and I think I
missed my era very Elizabeth back look
right there she was in that film as well
and Seabiscuit all right let's see let's
roll with the next one right here we got
another photograph okay you're going to
Springsteen is your big Springsteen fan
did he open staples correct yes yes I
mean from the New York New York area so
I mean I have to know everything about
Springsteen yeah I actually I think I'm
gonna give away those tickets because I
don't have anybody to go with one so I'm
not gonna make my do you want to go I
offered them too so I offered them to
Jay Mohr first okay because I know he's
a little bit awkward for you let's see
what else we have over there can we run
through them there we go all right there
so now when was this business before
they open this the stadium open yeah
well it was last November and and I
couldn't get over this that beautiful
statue it's really something to see in
person I'm not seeing it yet
oh you have to it's a great selfie spot
were you checking out any of your
players in your fantasy league I'm
looking through here and I don't see any
Falcons right there but I
yeah I see I'm imagining Brown was your
first draft choice right and 2000 Brown
yeah and then they just they put it in
order yeah I know cuz I saw that I'm
like she's drafting Blake bortles do you
want to talk a little fantasy football
with you as well Jamie boss is here in
the Rich Eisen show back with more Timon
[Music]
all right back with Jeannie buffs the
controlling owner of the Lakers and CEO
live on the Rich Eisen show what was the
first time you met magic your first time
you ever oh my gosh the first time I
ever met magic you know back in the day
the the draft wasn't what it is today it
was they just called the players and
said oh you've been drafted
so once magic was drafted by the Lakers
they flew him out to LA and Bill Sharman
who was the general manager the team
brought him over to my dad's house and
my dad said you know Jeannie they're
gonna be coming over here I got some
stuff to do upstairs will you just bring
them in see them in the living room and
offer them something to drink so you
know I was 17 years old magic was 19 so
the doorbell rings I open it up and
there's this smile of this guy that just
you know was so fun watching on TV and
now I'm meeting him in person so he came
in we sat down he talked about how
excited he was to be drafted to the
Lakers but that he was only going to
stay three years until he could go home
and play for the Pistons and hold this
to you this is an upstairs and you know
I was panicked and I said dad you're not
gonna believe what he just told me that
that he's he wants to go home and play
for his team back home and my dad didn't
miss a beat when he said first time he
walks out on the floor at the Forum he's
never gonna leave that's what he said
that's what my dad said and he knew the
love affair that he had brought somebody
that the city would fall in love with
and and magic would fall in love with
the city and that's exactly what
happened
and you know magics never left often do
you remind magic but you know it kind of
made sense for who he was you know that
he you know how how much his hometown
means to him well I mean he is you know
mister Michigan State even to this very
day you know but he's mister Los Angeles
now he attentionally even more obviously
you know world-renowned yeah
in that regard yeah so how did you ever
sit back and go wow I'm now the
controlling owner of the Lakers
mhm and the guy who I am putting in
charge as as the person to make sure
that we get all the trophies in the case
is Magic Johnson you know it's it's
really how you know we were raised by
the same man basically dr. boss you know
magic coming to the team at 19 you know
my dad had a lot of influence and magic
was somebody who wanted to learn about
the business side of the operation and
you know it's it's so interesting
working with him because we see things
the same way because we were brought up
under the same philosophy and it's just
made you know putting the Lakers in this
kind of position so easy because he and
I both see what needs to be done and
we'll continue to do until you know
we've we've reached our goal which is to
be to make LA proud of this team well I
think you you're kind of already mission
accomplished there you know with LeBron
James coming here you just feel it you
just feel that I'm walking around the
town there's no question its palpable
sense of excitement and I know I don't
want so and that Kobe in particular is
excited about this is it true that he
texted you a game of Thrones me yes once
that the signing took place yes that's
true yes Kobe has been an inspiration
for me
he has been he's given me his time his
wisdom
you know he's he's a very thoughtful
yeah his agent and he's he's a he's a
very strategic thinker and I you know
sometimes I you know get and get too
caught up in the emotion of things and
so to have an influence like Kobe who
could kind of lay things out in a way of
you know what is the goal that you're
trying to accomplish Jeannie well then
here's how you have to look at it you
have to create a path you have to you
know and and you know do you have the
heart to do that do you have do you have
what it takes to to you know make things
the way you want them to be because that
sometimes takes you know bravery and
guts and courage and I think that you
know that conversation really inspired
me and I think that's where why he sent
me that gameofthrones me yes which is
exactly can you describe it just you
know the the character that they called
the mother of dragons Khaleesi Khaleesi
he's you think you're the Khaleesi of
the Lakers well he that that I had to
learn to be that that I had to you know
take control and and and define what it
was that I wanted to accomplish and and
I wrote back to him when he sent that to
me I said that you allowed me to see
what I couldn't and just in terms of
taking control of this yeah yeah yes
that I that I would make tough decisions
because it involves family and and
sometimes it's hard to make a business
decision that you know is is you know
family it's it's just different and you
know he he you know he was happy for me
and he was happy to see cuz he knew I
can do it and he's you know a father of
three daughters and he's very much about
empowering his his daughters well and
and the situation that you set up for
the team you know
paved the road for LeBron coming
here and there's so many people in this
town that think that he's now want to
talk about Game of Thrones
I guess realm treading on on the turf
LeBron is treading on Kobe's turf here
where do you stand on this subject of
treading on Kobe's turf with him coming
here well I think that anybody that
would you know any Laker fan like
they're not Laker fans if they're not
happy about LeBron joining the team so
you know there was some unrest and some
uneasiness and I just think those are
troublemakers that that you know they
they don't get it
I think Los Angeles is going to be very
proud of the way that LeBron will
represent the Lakers team and they're
gonna fall in love with him too so
what's more of a truthful rumor Kobe's
not happy about LeBron coming that's not
where Kobe would be interested in coming
out of retirement to play with LeBron
I'm always constantly trying to get Kobe
to get more involved he's got so many
other projects though he's got an Oscar
he's like so creative and he's got so
many different things he knows he knows
how much I need him and how how much his
support means to me he always has an
open door to anything that he wants to
do with the Lakers including coming back
on the floor yeah I mean you know I
think his his wife Vanessa would kill me
you know I mean like I said Kobe Kobe
can do anything in my book all right
let's take a 60-second break come back
we have a game called start bench cut
here where we give you a choice of three
we got to start one bench one and cut
one to some interesting aspects there
and I do want to hit a little bit on
Lonzo ball and his future with this team
that's the 60 seconds with Jeanne bust
back here on the Rich Eisen show
a lot of people you know kind of kind of
just rule us out just cause we're young
like like we're hungry we're competitive
you know anybody that watched his play
last year we were in a lot of games like
no I had one of the greatest players a
long time that's all you're gonna know
raise what we do and you'll raise our
level of focus to even higher level so I
don't I don't really see why there's so
patient in there
that's Kyle Koosman who burst on the
scene last year for the Los Angeles
Lakers and is one of the young Lakers
that are around with LeBron James coming
here Jeanie buss here on the Rich Eisen
show and I want to say around there was
a lot of conversation that's a lot of
these young kids could be sent elsewhere
during the free agency period to perhaps
acquire another player how was that
possible you know it's again I deferred
to our you know our had a basketball
Magic Johnson I can't tie his hands he's
got to do what he feels is best for the
team and I know his agenda is only to
make the Lakers better and to win and so
I have to I have complete faith in him
that he will make decisions that will
get us there it was it close though
we're we're good close a blockbuster
trade close when LeBron was in the mix I
know I don't know what kind of
conversations they had they wouldn't
they wouldn't burden me with all that
for all the different things that go on
on a day to day basis but they know how
I feel I feel why you know I love the
players that we've drafted my youngest
brother Jesse bas runs our scouting
department and he has found us players
you know like a Kyle Kuzma that was a
late first round pick who now I think if
the draft was held again he'd be a top
five pick you know finding players like
Josh Hart who can come in and and
contribute you know I I love our youth I
love our young players and I get
attached you know very strongly to
players I would probably still have
Shaquille O'Neal plain but you know I
think that again I trust magic knows
exactly what he's trying to build and
with Lonzo ball the fact that rajon
rondo was acquired has left a lot of
people scratching their head saying is
there a competition here is this Lonzo
have to play for his starting role on
this team you know i think if you want
to talk basketball stuff maybe have Luke
Walton here rob blink III can't you know
I can't tell you what's gonna happen all
I know is that rajon rondo
was a strong contributor to his team
last year and we need a player like that
the consistency the experience the
winning that he has behind him I think
is only gonna help every player on our
team and Luke Waltons future where do
you see it from your I favor seed Lucas
is has an ability to connect with people
like I've never seen he's very he can
disarm you know any group of people any
you know people want to play for him
they want to please him he's he's just a
good people person and you know I feel
for him because we didn't give him the
kind of talent that he needed to be
successful he chose to come here after
being with Golden State for their
championship and you know a coach can
only be as good as the players that he
has given on his roster and I think Luke
has shown what kind of basketball he
wants to play and I think he's he's
developed our young players to the point
where somebody like the LeBron James
would want to come and play for him so I
know again I know you're very happy with
your management team what do you think
of when you see Jerry West though with
the Clippers you know Jerry is you know
somebody who is has proven his himself
time and time and time again as a player
as
front office you know he's a true
professional he was under contract went
to another team when we made the when I
made the changes to our basketball front
office and you know I wish him the best
he he knows what he's doing the logo the
logo use that what do you think of when
you drive around town you see all the
the warrior stuff you know around here
they're very popular as you know yeah
you know that's what happens is you
capture kids imagination when they're
you know seven eight nine years old and
the the Warriors have been everywhere
they've they've won and they've done you
know I have to hand it to them as an
organization they know how to put
winning teams together they keep
improving the addition of DeMarcus
Cousins was you know great for them and
you know they're the competition they
set the bar so you know we want to try
to do what they've done they good for
the league absolutely I think any any
organization that goes after winning
does what it takes they're building
they're opening a new arena not this
season but next season that will you
know set a new bar for this league and
and that's what it's all about
joonie bus here on the Rich Eisen show
we do this with many guests so we're
appreciative of you being here let's
play start bench cut we're gonna give
you three choices you have to start one
bench one and come on here with Jeanie
buss here we go start bench cot with
Jeanie buss the controlling owner of the
lake hey you said anything's anything's
game here okay here we go the owner and
the NBA most likely to reach for the
check at dinner okay you've got a start
one bench one and cut one okay Paul
Allen owner of the Blazers Mark Cuban
owner of the Dallas Mavericks James
Dolan the owner of the Knicks
you have to start one who's more likely
to pick up a check at dinner
Jim Dolan he's bought me dinner many
times and then I I guess I would have to
to you know I would have to to bench
I guess Mark Cuban and then cut Paul
Allen cuz Paul he's never invited me to
dinner okay so out of just because he's
never had dinner
Dolan's bought you many times okay is
that because he's you know he all owns
the forum now pretty much no no he and I
are were very good friends and I'm a fan
of his music I know you are he has you
are JT in the straight shot yes I've
seen them a few times they're great
where we'd love for you to whisper in
James's ear about a couple of things
selling the team that's the end of that
former Laker who would be best as a
late-night talk show host we're removing
magic from this piece has already done
it
Kobe Shaq or Metta World Peace who would
be best at being a host of a late-night
talk show stark bench cut really hard
for me I would I would have to start
Kobe because I know Kobe would do deep
dives into every guest that he had you
know I guess on the bench would be Shaq
because he he's so entertaining
I can watch Shaq do anything and and
laugh and have fun and then I just you
know I guess just by virtue of numbers
that like meta I'm sorry I have to cut
you you disappointed me on Big Brother
Celebrity Big Brother choice juicy Shaq
on Shark Week oh my gosh he's it's like
you haven't lived until you've gone to a
party where Shaq is the DJ because he
can get a party just bouncing off the
walls he's so fun I was on the all-star
Celebrity game for for Major League
Baseball in DC I ran into him in the
lobby of a hotel he's the best okay here
we go
a next start bench cut for GE bus
favorite ball Lucille
Lavar basket Lucille Lavar basket
favorite ball okay you know I'm gonna
have to go with the the you know well
it's a tie it's this is hard I mean it's
it's got to be NBA because that's all
basketball would and then you know I
would have to say you can a bench
Lucille or levar I guess I have to to
bench the bar relationship with the bar
it's great I you know all the parents
and significant others spouses of
players that that come into our team you
know I I like to connect with because
that's family and so you know I've had
great times with him he's he loves his
kids
I admire that mm-hmm have you ever had a
conversation with his with him about his
propensity to say things into a
microphone that might create a problem
now I mean he's it's like he's hit
his opinions are his own they're not
opinions of the organization so he's
he's a free person to do whatever and
say whatever you want okay notice start
bench cut here we got a little serious
there well but that's what happens when
you bench him over Lucille Ball I take a
little bit of Enbridge their favorite
Jack Nicholson movie One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest The Shining a few good men
the shining because I mean there's a
reason why Jack Nicholson seat is next
to the visiting bench because that that
character he played in the shining you
never know if he's gonna be he's like
part of our home court advantage okay
so Jack Torrance is the reason why you
sitting there they start you what do you
bench and cut Cuckoo's Nest in a few
okay
Oh Cuckoo's Nest is next and then I
guess I have to cut a few good men
what's your favorite story jack story
you got one that you can tell you know
he's I think I mean the most touching
story for me was he wanted to come to
chick Hearns memorial that that was
important to him that he loved Chick
Hearn and you know you you just don't
think that Jack thinks that way but he
does did he go did he show mmm-hmm it's
really getting a little emotion yeah I
mean I'd let I'll of technical sin he's
been such a part of our team it's a big
part of our team and I will be happy to
see him on opening night yeah against
the Rockets right after and after a game
in Portland right and a Saturday night
we never open on a Saturday well you can
do that with LeBron at home last one for
you number it gives your fantasy
football player start bench cut number
one pick if you get the number one pick
in fantasy football this year start
bench cut who do you choose Gurley Bell
or David Johnson Todd Gurley are you
kidding me okay your Los Angeles first
might actually win this year no okay and
then I guess your Bell and our David
Johnson who do you bench in court cut
there
I guess I guess I bench bow and cut
there you know it's okay that's the
whole process that somebody's got to be
cut that's the whole process here who's
League are you in I was Ashley oh why
not you indolence there I was actually
in two different leagues but that I'm
actually not playing this year what
happened no I've been I love fantasy
football I just I just I'm uncomfortable
with the the Washington team name and I
just no kidding I just don't want to it
just it's uncomfortable for me so just
it took all the fun out of it for me
really yeah so you just won't even play
fantasy football because but I'm still
huge Rams fan and a Chargers fan because
they're both here in LA but Todd Gurley
is is he's a Laker fan and he's sat with
me a couple times there's we just put
the picture up right there Todd father
right there he's he's a winner for the
Rams yeah no doubt about that
okay Jeannie thank you for coming on you
appreciate it
see you're just down the road this is
we're just up the road for me I'll be
knocking on your door it works both ways
we might be knocking on yours as well
thanks for coming on greatly appreciate
it and by the way the official Lakers
podcast hosted by my wife every single
week it's gonna be great yeah we're
gonna have a lot of fun building a great
that's pretty cool that you it's the
first official podcast of any team in
the ending Association right and I love
that a woman-owned run team is we've got
a woman running our podcast for podcast
one on earth norm pattice would say
she's running it well that's right next
to the visiting bench okay thanks very
much next time James Dolan buys you
dinner yes would you give me a call so I
can you know tell him a couple of
thoughts of what the mix would you mind
doing that
Jim Dolan is a good guy
okay liking Jim here Jeanne you got
Jeanne boss here on the Rich Eisen show
ty law in studio next hour the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience